Seth
your first script is super bad yeah and
I heard that you watched Harold and
Maude yeah in the process of writing
that script I had an influence on you it
did I will say it was actually it was
the last detail was also had a major
influence on obviously it's kind of a
ridiculous thing to say but you know the
time I was you know me and Evan my
writing partner we're kind of a very
against kind of for no reason kind of
what we considered Hollywood conventions
which I'm sure is a revolutionary
thought for a writer but I should also
say I was 17 years old but uh it just
seemed like any attempted emotion on for
us was sell out and stupid in a
Hollywood convention you couldn't have a
great comedy and be emotional at the
same time and it just didn't seem like
anything I would ever be interested in
as someone who goes to movies and then
we watched Harold and Maude was judges
had all these posters in his house so
I'd be like what are these movies and
and his daughter's name is Maude and so
eventually I was like I should probably
see this movie and and I washed it with
Jason Segel and I just cried like his
stare like hard crying like like years
of crying getting out but it's also
really really funny so I thought this
how I should be guy is on to something
and and we but you know and we had this
script super bad and it was just it was
just filthy there was just profanity and
it basically and Judd was imploring us
to sort of add some sort of undercurrent
of emotion perhaps and we thought no you
know you can't do that you can't have
the filth that we want and emotion in
the same movie it just won't work and
then we watch the last detail and we
just had our minds blown and we thought
this is literally everything we would
ever hope to accomplish in a movie you
know and and it's still you know it's
one of the few movies that I can like
show my friends that I grew up with it
like you would consider a film you know
that they would teach classes about and
my friends all love it and they laugh at
it and
and it's like you know I try to show
them some of my movies and they walk out
in ten minutes so uh it's it's you know
to me it was amazing to see someone that
was able to comedic ly do anything I
would ever hope to do and at the same
time made me cry profusely which is
something I never would ever want to do
but it's ultimately a good thing to get
out of your audience I would think so
yeah it was very eye-opening for me in
many many ways
you